记住，不要试图去改变你的父母，不要试图去说服你的父母，不要试图让你的父母觉得他们曾经做错了什么，不要让你的父母说他们懊悔了，羞愧了，他们来向你道歉了。我跟你说，不存在，跟您介绍一下我家的原生家庭的情况是这样的啊，是我爸妈属于是八九十年代那个时候的，后来，就是因为重男轻女超生我弟弟，然后导致他们两个工作中被开除了。然后，我有一个妹妹，我就是家里的老大，14岁多，初中毕业的时候就没能上学。那个时候，家里面发生了一系列的那种，就是我弟弟手又被炸断了，家里面就很多这种不好的事情。那个时候，确实也是因为我爸爸，你弟弟现在多大了呀，我弟弟现在比我小10岁26，他也没成家，是不是是的，他现在是手炸断断到哪个程度了呀？大拇指和小拇指两个就是几乎没用了，还剩三个指头，那还行啊，基本上生活是能自理的。哈，对生活能自理，以前我特别不能释怀的事情，但是后来就是通过你的话语真的找到了力量，就是我们要坦然接受，我们就是不被父母偏爱或者疼爱的孩子吧，你很多次讲的话真的完全戳中我的内心。这以前我很想证明，或者说以前讲的。
时候，我爸就经常会打我妈妈。嘛，那个时候他还是一个老师，在那个学校的宿舍里面经常打的我妈妈就是半夜三更，带着我躲到别人家去。就在我的内心，这种创伤其实是很严重的，就是我看到他以前我就害怕，就浑身发抖，就导致我十几岁来外面给了我300块钱。我从我们的老家兴义来到贵阳好多年春节，我在这边一个人在贵阳生活打工啊，就当服务员啊，好多工作都做过。那个时候，他们真的也没有关心啊，或者说告诉你要怎么保护自己啊。然后那些年真的是吃了很多苦，然后也上了很多当。以前二十几岁的时候，我真的对他们会一点埋怨的心都没有吧。加上我们家本来就不是一个原生家庭，有温暖和爱的那种环境，所以我当时觉得能摆脱出来，其实也还觉得挺开心的，可以一个人在外面，不用再像以前一样出去玩，担心回家被打呀什么的。后面就是到了我21岁的时候吧，我自己打工赚了钱去读夜校，在那个时候就认识了我第一段没有进入婚姻，就没领证的那个我大女儿的爸爸吧，然后那个时候，就是因为当时他有条件吧，就给我父母在我的老家买了一套房子。但当时其实我可以选择在贵阳买的，可是我。
没有我就选择了在老家，因为我就想让我弟弟妹妹有一个稳定的居所，不像以前我一样老是要收拾着行李打包在那种口袋里，就搬家呀什么的那种画面嘛。我就特别想改善他们的那种生活环境吧。现在你成家了吗？成家了有孩子了吗？有我还有一个小女儿，就是你跟那个第一个那个男朋友是生了个儿子，是不是女儿？你是女儿，现在总共有两个闺女，现在过得咋样呢？两口子感情好吗？感情还可以吧。然后过得物质方面的话，说实话，就现在的话，在这种小城市也还可以吧。我们有几套房子，然后也有一个门面房在收租，然后就像您讲的一样，我现在就是有时候情绪会内耗我自己的事，我以前二十几岁的时候真的从来不会说去埋怨他们或者怎么样。我的第一种就是像那样啊，结束了以后，我妈还讲那种很扎我心的话，就是他们都没有对我付出太多。然后我像这样子对他们，他们从来没有对我进行过，不管是直接的口头上的或者行动上的，让我感觉到他们好像会感激你的付出一样的感觉。你现在最困惑，你的心里面最疙瘩的事情是不是跟爸妈的关系？我跟爸妈的关系现在是这样的，因为这么多年就是在我以前没。
没有这个能力和条件的时候，我就把一个家的那种责任一定肩扛了。然后，我妹妹读研究生啊，读大学啊，包括她后来大学毕业考上工作了，又脱产去考研究生的时候，她跟我商量的时候，我还是表示支持他。然后，他上研究生啊，大学的费用，我爸妈其实没有对我提出过明确的这种要求，但是我基本上就是承担了一半，然后这么多年我父母都是我在管嘛支持嘛。现在就是什么个情况呢？就是我爸妈现在都是跟我生活在一块儿，因为我现在的老公婆婆在浙家，他也不跟我们生活在一起了。如果我妈妈在我家，那我就不需要额外花钱请一个阿姨。但是如果我妈妈不在我肯定是要请个阿姨，然后，关键是之前我爸爸在跟你一起生活的时候，其实我的内心很抗拒和他，尤其是我和他单独相处，我选择了让他一个人生活在我老家。但是，因为前年他带着你的时候就得了一次脑梗，他去住院了以后，我回来，你不知道，我一晚上做梦都在想，我在问我自己，如果他生病了，要花10万块或者20万30万去救他的时候，我感觉我真实的想法就是，如果钱花太多了我肯定会有点动摇。但是呢，也并不是我不能达到的。如果我做一下，肯定是可以。但是这么些年他和我生活在一块，还有就是中途发生了一些。
事情我特别不能理解他，但是现在我确实听了你的话语变勇敢了吧，我反抗他了，就像今年有一次，我真的就第一次就是这样会还击他就他有时候还小无赖一样讲那种话，还来怼我就说他穷了他还跟我妈妈说现在是我有钱了，然后讲话就怎么啦怎么啦，就讲这种话，就让我觉得特别不负责任。老师会去推荐你现在希望龙飞帮你分析的点是什么？就是我如何跟他们保持。如果我以后不怎么管他们了，或者怎么样的话，我要怎么去平衡自己心里的道德加锁。你要多听一些跟原生家庭相关的一些课程，多看一些跟原生家庭相关的一些书籍。你要了解父母和孩子之间的关系的本质是什么，一定要学会找到那个自洽的点，自洽的点是什么？就是说，可能你小的时候有很多伤害是他们造成的，比如说你的爸爸打你的妈妈，但小的时候可能他偶尔也会对你释放过一些关心和善意。我觉得在心里面找到那个自洽的点，就是我作为女儿，我做到现在这个程度，我做的够不够，比起其他人来说，比起你身边周围的人来说，我做的已经够够的了。我自己心里这杆秤就持平了，就是这个意思。就是你作为女儿，你养了她多少年，你为她提供这个衣食无忧的生活提供了多少年。
嗯，正常来说的话，其实父母和孩子之间是不能谈报恩这个话题的。姐妹们啊，我我知道我这个话说出来也挺大逆独道的，但我现在是这么认知的，包括我对我的孩子也别无所求的，父母和子女之间的关系是不能谈报恩这个话题的。这一点的话，其实我父母他从来没有对我提过这种要求，包括之前他讲话有点内涵，就是想在老家修房子什么的。因为他毕竟和我妈妈也是那个年代受过教育的这种知识分子吧，或者说他天生就是这样的人，就是他穷困潦倒，我弟弟手大，断了住院，在医院里面，他宁愿去贷款，然后也没有去问我们的这些。他自己的兄弟姐妹开口借钱，他这一点延迟倒是还有吧，就是他今年像这了以后，他在我面前像这样讲这种话，我就敢忘了他几句话，而且也是比较生气，我就说，你穷，你觉得是怪我吗？我跟你讲啊，第一不要试图去改变他们，第二，不要试图去说服他们。就是因为我从来没有这样和他正面当过，我像这样子反击他确实改变了，让我觉得看到他上了年纪了，然后又生了病，你错了他不是改变了他，只是现在没有钱，没有能力，他只是屈服了。屈服和改变是两个事情。来，姐妹们啊，你们一定要把这个概念搞清楚，很多东西。
他不是改变了我们真的很难去改变一个人的这个时候，只是他老了他病了他弱了他穷了他没办法了他屈服了而已。所以，父母和子女之间的关系什么时候我们能明白这个道理？我再也不试图改变我的父母，我不试图说服我的父母，我只要按照我的方法去对待你就可以了。那现在他如果生活在老家，反正我就给他基础进了这个生活费，是的，他想要修房子，他想要面子，他想要怎么怎么样的。你不要把这件事情担在你的身上，否则的话，到最后你这一辈子你又不被偏爱，然后你又付出最多，然后你付出最多的时候，他们到死的时候未必念你的好，你何苦来哉呢？记住，再跟你讲，所有的原生家庭不好的兄弟姐妹，包括男同学，记住，不要试图去改变你的父母，不要试图去说服你的父母，不要试图让你的父母觉得他们曾经做错了什么，不要让你的父母说他们懊悔了，羞愧了，他们来向你道歉了。我跟你说，不存在，以我对我们东亚父母的这种了解，不存在，他们就算有一天看上去语气缓和了，听上去他嘴巴上认输了，只不过是因为权力的中心转移了，就好比你已经当上皇帝了，在太上皇的面前，你说啥是啥。而他心里并。
没有因此觉得他错了，没有因此觉得他小时候不该这么对你。明白了吗？就是按照你的方式去对他，且心里接纳你的这种方式，你就有好日子过。对您说的很对我现在就是要尽量过好我自己的日子。对，就是这样式的一定不要试图去改变他，不要试图去说服他，不要试图去让他们发现他们曾经错了，让他们发现他们曾经怎么怎么地了，做父母做的不好了，没有意义。好的，谢谢你，老那就这样啊，我直播间应该有很多人会有共鸣吧，就是你也是那个不被偏爱的孩子，但是现在权利中心转移了之后，慢慢慢慢是吧，你一定要在心里找到那个平衡点。那个平衡点就是我想怎么对你对得起我的良心就够了，我想怎么对你我对得起我的良心就够了，不要想太多，不要那个什么内耗自己。我们整个东亚父母对孩子的那种关系，某种程度上坦率的说啊，可能需要我们这一代人，需要我们这一代人去重新认识父母和子女之间是什么样的关系。我们创造一个灵魂，生一个孩子出来，到底是为了什么？是为了他以后能够为我养老吗？是为了以后我老了的时候，别人不敢欺负我吗？是为了我老了的时候，有个人能够照顾我，能够保护我吗？还是说只是因为单纯？
我们有了那么多的爱，有了那么多时间和精力，愿意去陪伴浇灌一个幸福的灵魂，愿意让他在这个世界上去感受这个世间的人情冷暖，感受这个世间的风和日丽，让他去感受这个世界的美好与真实。这个真的是需要我们这一代人去琢磨明白，我们为什么要一个小孩儿？其实，我们的父辈，我们的祖辈，坦率的说，他们很多人生一个小孩就是功利的，或者说他们生一个小孩，他们没想明白，就是别人生他也得生到时间了就得生。这个话题再引申出来一个话题，这个话题是什么呢？我们想要这个世界怎么对待我们，我们就去为这个世界留下什么样的孩子。举个例子，我们希望这个世界是尊重女性的，那我们从现在开始就要教育我们的儿子怎么尊重女性。我们希望这个世界对女性是不造谣的，从我们自己开始就要告诉我的儿子，这辈子造别人谣的男人是可耻的。我们希望这个社会能够接纳女性的优秀，接纳女性成绩比他好，那我们就要教育我们的儿子愿意去接纳这个事实。可能有的女孩子她成绩就是比你好，你就要接纳这个事实。就是所有的姐妹们啊，我们都得把剪刀把我们在际当中受到的那些不公平给剪掉。
不管我们生的是儿子还是女儿，如果我们生的是女儿，假设你小的时候有没有被教育过，不可以做男孩子的衣服。你小时候有没有被教育过，不可以跨男孩子的头。你小时候有没有被教育过？女生来例假的时候不可以坐这里，坐那里好像是不洁的这样一个状态，有没有啊？有的扣一。我小的时候就被妈妈被奶奶被姑妈被各种人教育过。以后如果我生了女儿的话，我就告诉她，你想做你就做，家里你想坐哪里都可以。出门在外，如果有别人觉得你不应该坐在他那个地方，是别人的地盘，你可以尊重她。但是从妈妈的这个角度来说的话，女孩子没有什么不洁，没有什么立下羞耻，没有什么，胯下羞耻不存在。
嗯。